[Música]
[Aplausos]
misiles que se caen cazas de combate que
no pueden disparar porque no tienen
munición y soldados alimentados con
comida caducada algunos pensará que esto
es el argumento de alguna comedia estilo
hot shots pero en realidad estamos
hablando de la invasión rusa de ucrania
durante años todos pensábamos que rusia
tenía una industria de defensa
envidiable sí es cierto la economía rusa
no es nada del otro mundo hablamos de un
país incapaz de exportar productos de
alto valor añadido como pueden ser
coches móviles o software pero la
industria de defensa era la joya de la
corona rusa para que os hagáis una idea
rusia tiene entre 2.5 y 3 millones de
personas trabajando en fabricación de
armamento esto supone el 20 por ciento
de los empleos industriales en este país
en otras palabras que parecía que el
armamento era la excepción que confirma
la regla habitual en rusia la única
industria que realmente funcionaba en
este país
así nos lo mostraba putin todos los años
en los desfiles militares todos los 9 de
mayo rusia celebra la victoria en la
segunda guerra mundial o como se dice en
ruso la gran guerra patriótica la plaza
roja de moscú se llena de gente para ver
el nuevo armamento de su ejército los
increíbles cazas sukoy su-34 hacen sus
acrobacias aéreas los modernos tanques
armadas se pasean por las calles y todo
el mundo se estremece cuando putin
muestra sus bombas nucleares delante del
kremlin y amigos de visual político
todos pensábamos que rusia tenía músculo
militar para poder tomar ucrania en
cuestión de días sin embargo la forma de
comprobar el poder militar de un país no
es en un desfile sino en una guerra y en
la invasión de ucrania estamos viendo
algo que ya viene siendo norma habitual
en la economía rusa una cosa es cuando
lo pides en el aliexpress ruso y otra lo
que te llega oficiales de eeuu aseguran
que algunos misiles rusos tienen una
tasa de fallo del 60 por ciento si mis
queridos amigos de visual política tras
un mes de invasión de ucrania podemos
decirlo claro el armamento ruso está muy
pero que muy por detrás de la
expectativas y el hype que habían creado
y esto es una sorpresa porque desde el
año 2008 la principal prioridad de putin
ha sido la modernización de su ejército
pensad que hablamos de un país que ha
llegado a gastar algunos años más del 5%
de su pib en defensa para que os hagáis
una idea alemania acaba de anunciar que
va a gastar un 2% y nos parece una
medida histórica en otras palabras rusia
ha puesto todos sus recursos en mejorar
su armamento es cierto que nadie se
esperaba que el arsenal ruso supera sal
de eeuu pero comparado con cualquier
otro país rusia parecía estar en la
vanguardia militar sin embargo estamos
viendo que ese armamento es un auténtico
desastre
[Música]
y la pregunta es por qué qué ha fallado
exactamente en la industria militar rusa
porque pese a haber invertido tantísimo
dinero rusia mantiene un arsenal tan
obsoleto hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes tenemos una
sorpresa para todos vosotros porque
aunque muchos ya lo sabéis tenemos un
nuevo hermanito en la familia de visual
político todos nos lo habíais pedido
cuando vais a sacar un canal sobre
economía seamos claros esta era la pata
que necesitaba visual política un canal
donde habláramos de cosas como qué es la
deuda perpetua qué problemas tiene el
sistema eléctrico o quién es george
soros más allá de las teorías de la
conspiración pues bien todo eso son
temas que encontraréis en visual que
económico terminado en que de visual
política así que ya sabéis os esperamos
en visual económico y ahora sí vamos a
ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el capitalismo sin empresas privadas
cual es el rifle de salto más famoso del
mundo exacto el ak-47 más conocido como
kalashnikov como seguramente sabréis
todos el kalashnikov es de fabricación
soviética con semejante icono de la
industria de defensa muchos pensaréis
que la unión soviética tenía un sector
armamentístico de primera sin embargo la
realidad era muy distinta si queréis
conocer a fondo el armamento soviético
os recomiendo que visitéis nuestro otro
canal hermano que se llama mega project
también con cada visual político en este
canal hemos sacado varios vídeos donde
analizamos todos los detalles técnicos
de muchos de los grandes buques insignia
del ejército soviético desde el mítico
caza mig-29 hasta los submarinos de la
clase tayfun os dejo los enlaces en la
descripción pero en resumen casi todas
las armas del arsenal soviético se
pueden resumir en un meme hay un mundo
de diferencia entre cuando lo pides en
el aliexpress soviético y cuando te
llega
[Música]
la industria militar soviética estaba
llena de empresas estatales que no daban
beneficios fábricas obsoletas y sobre
todo nos va a sorprender a nadie
muchísima corrupción veréis en eeuu hay
una alianza entre gobierno y empresas
privadas por lo hemos contado varias
veces aquí en visual política y está por
ejemplo el caso del f-35 washington
necesitaba renovar su flota de cazas de
combate que hicieran pues a grandes
rasgos hicieron un concurso donde se
presentaron varias empresas privadas en
este caso las principales candidatas ya
sabéis eran boeing y lockheed martin
finalmente lo que martín ganó el
concurso y se les adjudicó un contrato
millonario por supuesto que este sistema
tiene sus problemas las empresas
privadas quieren maximizar su beneficio
y eso explica la espiral de sobrecostes
del f-35 hablamos de más de 400 mil
millones de dólares que han salido
directamente del bolsillo del
contribuyente americano para engrosar la
cuenta de resultados de una empresa
privada por supuesto que este sistema
tiene muchísimos aspectos que podemos
criticar pero con todos sus problemas
este sistema ha conseguido que las
empresas americanas sean capaces de
desarrollar el armamento más puntero del
mundo es el resultado de décadas de
competencia entre privadas
el comunismo soviético sin embargo se
basa en la idea contraria es decir toda
la economía dependía del estado la
defensa se basaba en monopolios
estatales y los resultados están a la
vista pero ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando a ver fonseca que hace 30 años
que desapareció la unión soviética rusia
ya ha abandonado el comunismo y si
tenéis razón nadie en su sano juicio
diría que vladimir putin se un comunista
convencido y es verdad rusia lleva
décadas en un sistema que tiene muy poco
que ver con la revolución bolchevique
ahora bien rusia nunca ha abrazado el
capitalismo de libre mercado os lo hemos
contado mil veces aquí en visual
político aunque rusia haya abandonado el
comunismo todavía mantiene una economía
muy pero que muy centralizada es decir
el estado sigue manteniendo un rol
fundamental en todas las industrias no
se incluye lógicamente el armamento y la
pregunta que muchos estaréis haciendo es
y dónde está el problema de verdad es
tan importante que las armas las
fabrican empresas privadas cómo se puede
modernizar todo el arsenal de un país
sin competencia entre empresas es
posible pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el pensamiento siloviki
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos si
quieres que tus empresas sean
competitivas lo mejor que puedes hacer
es privatizar las para que compitan
entre ellas verdad pues sí esto es lo
que diría la lógica económica liberal
pero la rusia de putin tiene una lógica
muy distinta según vladímir putin el
problema del comunismo no era una
economía centralizada sino una economía
basada en principios ideológicos es
decir que si quieres mejorar la
eficiencia del sistema basta con cambiar
los directivos y poner al frente a
tecnócratas tecnócratas que se han
forjado en el seno de la calle y que
tiene una mentalidad totalmente
pragmática y libre del romanticismo del
comunismo o de cualquier otra ideología
pues bien este tipo de persona tiene un
nombre siloviki y por eso cuál ha sido
la receta de putin para llevar a su
industria militar al siglo 21 es muy
sencillo poner a los siloviki en todos
los puestos directivos así es como en el
año 2007 nació rostec un conglomerado de
empresas diseñado para ser el gran
paraguas de la defensa rusa bajo este
paraguas están más de setecientas
empresas de armamento todas ellas
propiedad del estado
[Música]
gracias a la empresa se pueden eliminar
un montón de duplicidades todo ello
siguiendo los criterios puramente
tecnócratas de los siglo x por supuesto
quién es el ceo de rostec pues nada
menos que es serguéi chémezov quien fue
compañero de trabajo del mismo vladimir
putin cuando ambos estaban en las
oficinas de la calle en alemania del
este dicho de otra forma un siloviki de
manual y diréis de verdad rostec ha
servido para eliminar costes pues lo
cierto es que si para que os hagáis una
idea en el año 2008 todas las empresas
bajo el paraguas de rose text sumaban la
plantilla de 388 mil trabajadores en
2014 se trataban de sólo 443 mil
trabajadores y desde su fundación rostec
no ha dejado de absorber todo tipo de
empresas de armamento incluso han
permitido que entre cierto capital
privado en alguna de las grandes
armamentísticas rusas queréis un ejemplo
pues os doy un ejemplo los fabricantes
de ese mítico ak-47 el 74% de jsf
kalashnikov concern está ahora mismo en
manos privadas
sin embargo la expansión de rostec tiene
un problema cual es que al adquirir más
y más empresa rostec ha terminado
consolidando aún más monopolios por
ejemplo los cazas de combate eeuu
trabaja con cuatro grandes fabricantes
boeing lockheed martin raytheon y hervás
ya lo sé hervás es europea pero también
tiene contratos con washington en el
caso de rusia prácticamente todos los
cazas de combate están fabricados por
una única empresa y hace que por
supuesto está debajo del paraguas de
roster y diréis pero de verdad basta con
colocar un silo vicky de estos al frente
de un monopolio para hacer que sea más
competitivo pues podéis juzgar por
vosotros mismos otra de las grandes
empresas de defensas rusas es almaz
antei esta empresa no depende del roster
al menos no todavía sino que
directamente es propiedad del ministerio
de finanzas ruso el feo de esta empresa
es otro siloviki de manual en este caso
hablamos de víctor iván of ex agente del
cajero almaz antei es el gigante dónde
se encuentra np o novato que es el
fabricante de casi todos los misiles de
precisión rusos y justo esos misiles que
están demostrando ser tan defectuosos en
la invasión de ucrania y lo cierto es
que nada de esto es una sorpresa para
que os hagáis una idea en el año 2017 np
o novatos sólo podía producir 60 misiles
caliber en seis meses como os podéis
imaginar estas cifras son ridículas si
tenemos en cuenta que en sólo un mes de
guerra en ucrania rusia ha lanzado ya
más de 1200 misiles
y os preguntaréis pero de verdad nos
está diciendo fonseca que no hay ninguna
empresa privada en todo el complejo de
defensa ruso pues lo cierto es que sí
que hay alguna por ejemplo recordáis las
latas de comida caducadas que
suministran a los soldados que están en
el frente de ucrania pues atentos cabal
ni desenmascara un cartel que
supuestamente ha ganado miles de
millones de rublos en contratos de
defensa rusos adivinar de qué cartel
estamos hablando exacto se trata de un
entramado de empresas de cátering
propiedad de un tal y evgeny trigo jean
quien o sorpresa es amigo personal de
putin este buen señor es un cocinero
propietaria de restaurantes y empresas
de catering según denunciaba el propio
alexéi navalni prigoshin trampeo todos
los sistemas de licitación públicas para
convertirse en el proveedor de comida
del ejército hoy en día naval ni están
en la cárcel y los soldados rusos
reciben latas de comida caducadas y la
pregunta que os estáis haciendo muchos
es hemos dicho que la fábrica de misiles
sólo era capaz de producir 60 unidades
de precisión en seis meses sin embargo
rusia ha lanzado más de 1200 misiles en
el campo de batalla como es posible de
dónde salen tantos misiles
mismo lo vamos a explicar
teoría versus realidad
la pregunta que todos los analistas
militares están haciendo en este momento
es cómo es posible que rusia no haya
sido capaz de lograr la supremacía aérea
es decir cómo es posible que rusia no
haya sido capaz de destruir todas las
defensas antiaéreas de ucrania de tal
forma que los cazas rusos puedan
bombardear y sobrevolar el territorio
ucraniano sin problemas pensando bien
ucrania sólo tiene 134 cazas de combate
y todos son de la época soviética rusia
tiene casi 1.200 cazas de los cuales 300
están listos para atacar ucrania
hablamos además de los cazas de combate
más modernos recordad que rusia ha
invertido miles de millones en
modernizar su ejército y ahí se incluye
la fuerza aérea ahí tenemos por ejemplo
esos su co y su 34 que tanto se
mostraban en los desfiles militares
estos cazas son unos bombarderos que se
empezaron a utilizar en el año 2008
sobre el papel los su co y su 34 no
tendrían nada que envidiar a los f-15 de
los eeuu podríamos decir que son uno de
los mejores cazas de combate de rusia el
problema el problema es que a duras
penas
y precisión para disparar habéis oído
bien puede sonar ridículo pero todos los
datos apuntan a que russian no tiene
suficiente munición de precisión para
esta guerra puede que sorprenda pero los
misiles de precisión caducan
habéis oído bien cada uno de estos
misiles que se dispara desde un avión
tiene una vida útil de entre 10 y 15
años eso significa que si quieres ir a
la guerra más te vale que tus fábricas
de armas estén fabricando a pleno
rendimiento sin embargo como ya hemos
visto las fábricas rusas tienen un
montón de problemas para producir en
masa conclusión pues estos sukoi su-34
de último modelo han estado disparando
munición convencional lo que podríamos
llamar bombas tontas es decir bombas que
caen donde caen eso explicaría noticias
tan terribles como este y tres muertos
en un hospital de maternidad bombardeado
por un ataque aéreo ruso pensarlo bien
atacar un hospital de maternidad no es
sólo una atrocidad también es un fallo
táctico el objetivo de un ataque es
destruir las defensas enemigas matar
niños en un hospital además de ser una
auténtica salvajada no cumple ningún
objetivo estratégico dicho de otra forma
este ataque no es simplemente el fruto
de un general malvado que quiera matar
niños es el resultado de no tener
misiles de precisión pero no sólo
hablamos de ataques mal planteados tener
pocos misiles de precisión plantea otro
problema a los aviones les obliga a
volar bajo y como os podéis imaginar si
un caza de combate vuela bajo se
convierte en un objetivo súper fácil
para cualquier cañón antimisiles
conclusión las fuerzas aéreas rusas
están perdiendo sus mejores cazas en
ucrania exacto en los mejores aviones de
rusia están cayendo como moscas por no
tener la munición adecuada
[Música]
ha aparecido ha ocurrido con los tanques
rusia ya ha perdido más de 400 tanques
en esta guerra además estamos viendo
cómo incluso la logística se realiza con
camiones civiles todo esto explica que
la invasión de ucranianos haya dejado
imágenes tan cómicas como esta
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
a ver fonseca de verdad estás diciendo
que los rusos son tontos y se han ido a
una guerra sin municiones pues no el
problema no es que los rusos sean tontos
el problema es que con un sistema
político con malos incentivos no se
genera otra cosa que fracasó lo hemos
dicho muchas más veces en visual
político y lo tenemos muchas más en
visual económico la economía rusa está
pensada para que ninguna empresa pueda
salirse del control de putin sus élites
en ese sentido rusia es totalmente
eficaz ahora bien a la hora de innovar
los siloviki son incapaces de generar
resultados así que una vez más nos
volvemos a encontrar con que hay un
océano de diferencia entre cuando lo
pides en el aliexpress siloviki y cuando
te llega y lo cierto es que esto no es
la primera vez que ocurre os acordáis de
la vacuna rusa contra el coronavirus la
famosa sputnik
[Música]
sobre el papel la vacuna funcional es
decir el diseño y la fórmula eran
correctos no sé si lo recordaréis pero
en aquel momento hubo un debate mundial
sobre la efectividad de la vacuna rusa
pues bien hoy en día ya nadie ha vuelto
a hablar de esta vacuna y ni siquiera
está aprobada por la oms dicho de otra
forma que es muy probable que en el caso
de la industria de defensa soviética nos
encontremos con un montón de casos como
el de la vacuna sputnik ub hablamos de
cazas de combate que sobre el plano son
un prodigio tecnológico pero que no
tienen munición tanques de último modelo
que no se pueden producir en masa porque
simplemente no hay fábricas disponibles
ni presupuestos visibles de precisión
que por lo visto no son tan precisos
como parecía y así un suma y sigue de
proyectos fracasados durante años al
entorno de putin los ha estado ocultando
pero ahora estamos viendo la eficacia de
estas armas en el campo de batalla y
estamos viendo que todas las
suposiciones que teníamos sobre la
economía rusa son ciertas ahora sólo
queda una incógnita en el aire y es la
dejo para que la responda jce en los
comentarios qué pasa con el armamento
nuclear ruso todos sabemos que rusia
tiene el mayor arsenal nuclear
putin ha llegado a amenazar con
utilizarlo la pregunta es de verdad
funciona y si buena parte de esas
cabezas nucleares
estuvieran caducadas de verdad esos
misiles intercontinentales son tan
efectivos como asegura el trending por
supuesto ninguno de nosotros queremos
comprobarlo pero qué pensáis será otro
hype de rusia podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
político sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos este canal y
como hemos dicho al principio no
olvidéis que aquí en visual política
acabamos de sacar un canal hermano
dedicado a la economía visual económica
con cara de visual política no olvidéis
visitarlo y si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un saludo y nos vemos en visual
económico
[Música]